In this course, we're going to do a considerable amount of algorithm analysis,
which is why we're going to do an overview of the techniques and notations that we're going to use.
If you've already had an algorithm course before and it terms like Big O-notation or RAM
or a worst-case running time are already meaningful to you, then you might try
and go directly for the quizzes for the respective sections.
Let's try it out with a little quiz.
What I want you think about is the various factors that we need to take into account
when we are analyzing an algorithm or more precisely, when we are analyzing the running time
of an algorithm because that would depend on the number of factors.
What I would like you to think about is what factors
can determine the running time of an algorithm.
So here are six different possibilities.
First the size of the input, secondly the content or structure of the input,
third the type of computer that we are using for the algorithm,
fourth the amount of memory the computer has, five how the algorithm is implemented,
and six the programming language that we're using to implement the algorithm.
I want you think of each of those six aspects and then make a check mark
where you think that this aspect can influence the running time of an algorithm.